[Music]
hello you are watching The Press preview
a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive in the next half an
hour we'll see what's making headlines
with the leader writer at the Daily
Telegraph Tim Stanley and the political
correspondent at the guardian Elita I do
so let's take a look at what is on some
of those front pages front page of the
telegraph the growing pressure on the
NHS is their lead story it says that
thousands of people every day are having
to endure 12 hour long waits in hospital
a e
The Observer leads with news that
Britain's first major post-brexit trade
deal signed with Japan has been a
failure because it says it's in exports
it's actually full
the migrant crisis is top story in the
express which says that migrants are to
be housed in forces homes while
thousands of service veterans don't have
a roof over their heads
in the wake of a damning report into the
London Fire brigaze the time says that
these Services chief officer is
promising to sack workers guilty of
sexism or racism
the sun claims an exclusive with the
story that prince Andrew is apparently
Furious the disarmed protection is set
to be axed in the wake of him being
stripped of his Royal duties
and Scotland on Sunday pays tributes to
the rugby Legend Doddy whip who's died
from motor neurone disease
the Sunday people their headline core
mageddon it says that rocketing costs
are forcing Britain's Curry restaurants
to close
and the Sunday mirror's own exclusive
tells us that England lioness Jill Scott
is set to make a fortune off the back of
her appearance in I'm a celebrity
and the star says that MPS to get a
luxury Christmas dinner this year at the
same price as last bearing in mind that
the costs of living crisis the paper
says that is a Sprouts of order order
and just to remind you that by scanning
that QR code that you see on your screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch along with us well let's bring
in our guests as I said I'm joined
tonight by Tim Stanley and Elite Tim
Alita very nice to have you with us good
Saturday evening to you both let's start
with the front page of the times and Tim
this is the line out of a manston and
after saying that diphtheria was not the
cause of this person's death it does
appear as if this person who's at the
processing center has actually died of
dip Theory tell us more
but that's true although reading the
times this report uh do I say I read
that they had contracted dip Theory I'm
not quite sure if the times confirms
they definitely died of it but I might
be wrong about that
um nonetheless the story here is that uh
over there have been over 70 cases
what did Theory among people who are
moved out of Manson and into other
living accommodation Manson if you
remember is the processing center where
refugees are only spent supposed to send
spend a small period of time but due to
backlogs in the system there was a
terrible overcrowding it's only meant to
hold about 1 600 people at any given
time at one point it was holding
something close to four thousand
and some people including someone who
died while at the center had been
staying there for a very long time that
individual had stayed for over a week
there was a big row within the home
office about why this was happening who
was responsible so when a braverman's uh
uh as well a braveman that said that the
problem was simply that so many people
were coming in but it wasn't possible to
find accommodation for them elsewhere in
time others have said actually sowella
braveman and her staff chose not to try
and find full accommodation for everyone
else so there was a big round in the
home office about who was responsible
for that but either way now emerges that
there was dip Theory at manston it has
been spread because people have been
moved on it is of course a highly
serious a very communicable disease and
it looks like there hasn't been
sufficient testing of the people who
went through Madison to see if they had
diphtheria and so that's that's the
background of this story and of course
it all feeds into widespread fears about
Britain being overwhelmed uh by migrants
and not having the infrastructure to
cope with them or process them swiftly
yeah analitha as Tim uh says this has
sort of highlighted the the way that the
home office has reported what was
actually taking place at manston and the
sort of changing Narrative of what was
actually happening at that Center
problem started when this Home Secretary
Bradman first got her post uh earlier
this year and this wasn't a problem
under the former Home Secretary pretty
Patel
um but ultimately it has been found that
Sue Ella brevmond essentially didn't
want to uh commit to giving migrants
more hotels so this was probably the
best way for her to do so and she claims
um it has been claimed rather that you
know this would be you know one way of
solving the migrant crisis this is a
home secretary that when she was
defending herself in the House of
Commons earlier this month she was
comparing the channel crisis to
something of an invasion something
that's been criticized widely amongst
many tourian peers who do not see uh her
actions or her languages particularly
helpful within their constituencies or
for the party largely that is facing
much difficulty in the is we probably
discussed later on in this show
um but ultimately you know diphtheria is
something as Tim said that's extremely
serious and in 2020 I think there was
only one case of it in the UK when I was
seeing confirmed more than 70 cases
because a Home Secretary didn't want to
roll out more protection in hotels and
places to stay for these people in
desperate need it's it's not looking
good for the Home Secretary I mean many
of her own colleagues said they would be
extremely surprised to learn if she
would be still in the job come Christmas
time maybe she thought she escaped this
crisis by you know proving that she
could fight her colleagues and
opposition MPS in the Commons earlier
this month but clearly you know this
this story is only going to keep
developing as we hear of more confirmed
reports and obviously yes there has been
one person that sadly died we don't know
if that has been confirmed as a link to
diphtheria But ultimately it's just you
know it's a bad case in her watch yeah
let's sort of stick with the story of
migrants if we can uh both of you and go
to the front page of the Sunday Express
and uh Elita we'll start with you on
this one this is the Sun Express uh this
is exclusive that migrants are to be
housed in forces homes just lay out the
reporting here
yes essentially
um the express rightly says that there
are more than you know two and a half
thousand British veterans that are still
homeless
um it's sort of hits the two parties
against each other whereas you know I
don't think we should be looking at it
like that at all
um you know we are hearing of more than
500 uh Asylum Seekers from Afghanistan
that came here with the Afghanistan
scheme they had been working with
British forces overseas
um so they had they have the right to be
in this country and but they are still
displaced sort of you know in temporary
accommodation and the report highlights
the fact that they may be housed in you
know potential properties that could
have been used for for British vets
ultimately again we're just hearing of
you know bad mismanagement of properties
from the government you know there's
more than enough to go around ultimately
why aren't they helping both of these
groups of people that rightly deserve
such space that really deserve the
chance to have permanent accommodation
it's uh dumbfounding and Tim I mean is
that how you see it as well that there
is plenty of accommodation to go around
I I don't know if there is and even when
there is plenty of accommodation as some
people protest that accommodation being
used because you have cases of entire
hotels being taken over we've now got
veterans homes being used and antorian
is complain that people are being moved
into their constituencies and there are
the facilities for them there's the
local infrastructure for them ultimately
this comes down to whether or not Zola
braveman lied that to me is the
interesting political question I know it
sounds like I'm rather stacking stacking
things in favor of suggesting that she
might have done but her predecessors and
you'll remember there was two pretty
Patel and then Grand chaps for about
five minutes people linked to her
predecessors say that the policy was
always that they didn't like putting
people into hotels but they had a legal
obligation to provide provide
accommodation as soon as possible and
they say that for some reason
there was suddenly a log Jam when Sarah
Brightman took over so whether Brakeman
says I'm not lying I did try to find
people accommodation it's just that
people were coming in at such a fast
rate I couldn't possibly keep up with it
I think that that tension between those
two sides of the story is the thing that
will decide to enter braveman's future I
think at some point I think at some
point in the future the commons is going
to debate it again there's going to be a
proper investigation of it and we'll
find out which side is telling the truth
because it's really two completely
different takes on what went wrong here
yeah indeed and I guess we'll uh see how
that does play out Tim Aletha for now
thank you both very much let's just take
a quick look if we can um Elita at the
front page of the Sunday Times
um and this is the story that's been
leading on Sky News this evening about
uh the reporting from the London fire
brigade about the racist and
misogynistic culture
yes it's extremely horrifying and almost
quite depressing we've heard so much of
racism sexism misogyny from the
Metropolitan Police Force throughout
this year and for many years early to
learn and this is going on you know in
many other sectors
um ultimately the independent culture
review of the London fire brigade found
scores of examples people of ethnic
defense you know Muslims black people
um horrifying messages uh being sent
um within you know the workforce and
it's just quite alarming and shocking
um when you're hearing of a Muslim
firefighter who was founded terrorist a
terrorism hotline sticker I'm just
reading this from the front page near
his belongings when he returned from a
pilgrimage colleagues asked how his
Al-Qaeda training had gone I mean is
that acceptable in any sort of work for
Earth and we're hearing of the chief of
you know what is London's biggest fire
brigade that's London Andy Rose saying
that many many people will be sacked um
and it's just quite remarkable that
we're now at a stage where you know
teeths are coming to have to come
forward and confirm that they will suck
people because ultimately in many
sectors and many organizations we've
heard of such horrifying reports going
on and nothing is ultimately being done
about it okay we know that I'm sorry
it's Interruption we've run a short time
on this particular segment we're plenty
more from both you guys after this break
now uh still to come will continue
looking at tomorrow's papers including
this tribute from the Scotland on Sunday
for the rugby player bodywear
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview with me are Tim Stanley from The
Daily Telegraph and a link that I do
from the guardian Tim Alita thanks for
staying with us we haven't got long
before we uh have to go to another race
let's just get through the last couple
of stories here and so we'll start with
your publication Sunday Telegraph this
is saying that uh thousands of people
are still in a 12-hour wait for any
that's every day and this is as the of
course the Health Service is facing
increasing pressure and those strikes
coming in December
that's correct the figure is around 4
000 people 4 000 people a day are now
waiting for over 12 hours in a e and the
number of people who are waiting on a
trolley has risen by about 50 in one
year this of course is a hangover of the
chronovirus and lockdown we have
tremendous waiting lists uh it's not
going to be helped by the forthcoming
nurses strike which is going to add
extra pressures to the system around
Christmas plus you're going to have your
annual winter flu and of course just
recently the GP is in England uh voted
to limit their practicing hours to nine
to five uh saying that anything else
will be discriminated against people
with families and would therefore be
patriarchal
um so in other words the NHS is facing
insurmountable pressures or almost
insomatical pressures and as a result it
looks like England is starting to
develop really unusual mortality rate
which is to do not so much with
sicknesses and obviously everyone else
has to cope with but as to do with the
formulas of our particular Health System
uh thank you for being brief Tim and
Elita this will of course uh leads to
many people looking at the way the NHS
is funded and the amount of money that's
going to the Health Service
yes I mean also in the report from the
Sunday Telegraph we note that nurses are
on strike on the 15th and the 20th of
December and I found it interesting that
the health secretary Steve Barkley was
essentially accusing the Royal College
of nurses for essentially neglecting
patient safety for going on strike
because of the poor conditions and
because they feel amongst many workers
at the moment that they're unable to
keep up with the pressure whilst you
know struggling to make their own and
meet
um it's quite striking that nurses who
work for the 111 uh NHS service will
also be on strike during that time so it
will increase the pressure on services
so will the government cave in to their
demands to ensure that you know Brits
are healthy and well over the Christmas
period I mean I don't think it's looking
very likely but it's interrupture again
later we've run out of time but we'll
have more from both of you sorry I need
that Tim in the next hour thanks guys
thanks